vamos a encontrar la fórmula de la
derivada de la equis que yo creo que es
una de las cosas más increíbles
independientemente de cómo lo vea si
según el cálculo las matemáticas o el
universo bueno vamos a demostrar como ya
lo dije anteriormente que la derivada de
ea la x es exactamente a la x lo cual es
impresionante la pendiente de la recta
tangente en cualquier punto de la
gráfica de la función es igual a la
función en dicho punto vamos a ver que
esto es impresionante esto nos dice que
la segunda derivada en dicho punto es
igual a ese valor y que la tercera
derivada también o la enésima derivada y
que eso nunca va a dejar de sorprenderme
pero bueno volviendo al trabajo como
vamos a demostrarlo anteriormente hemos
probado y lo que hicimos antes de
empezar este vídeo es que la derivada de
bueno antes de continuar vale la pena
remarcar que algunos llaman a esto la
definición de un número tal que
satisface esta propiedad es una
situación un poco cíclica pero
nosotros ya hemos demostrado que es el
límite cuando n se aproxima al infinito
de 11 entre n a la n iv usando esto ya
hemos probado que la derivada del
logaritmo natural de x es igual a 1
entre x la derivada del logaritmo cuya
base es de x es 1 / x y vamos a usarlo
para demostrar lo siguiente
vamos a cambiar de colores para que esto
se mantenga interesante y vamos a tomar
la derivada del logaritmo natural de la
función ea la x
una situación casi trivial esto es igual
al logaritmo de al ave y es igual a bbc
es el logaritmo natural de a que será en
este caso la derivada de x por el
logaritmo natural de esto es decir a qué
^ es igual a e pues a la primera cierto
entonces esto es igual a la derivada de
x respecto a x que es igual a 1 creo que
ya lo hemos demostrado espero que sí
pero en caso de no haberlo hecho es algo
muy fácil de demostrar vale pues sí ya
lo hemos hecho vamos a hacerlo ahora por
este lado con la regla de la cadena que
dice la regla de la cadena sí tenemos
efe seguida de gx donde tenemos una
función dentro de otra la regla de la
cadena nos dice que hay que multiplicar
la derivada de la función interna que en
este caso es la derivada b
a la equis que es la función interna y
eso vamos a multiplicarlo por la
derivada de la función exterior evaluada
en la función interior lo podemos ver de
esa manera
la derivada del logaritmo natural de la
x respecto a la x aunque esto puede ser
lioso podrías haber escrito una de ea la
equis acá abajo en fin creo que sabemos
usar la regla de la cadena esto es igual
a 1 entre a la equis y viene de esta
expresión en vez de una equis tenemos ea
la x así que es una regla de la cadena
que más sabemos sabemos que esta
expresión de acá arriba es igual a esta
de abajo y también sabemos que es igual
a 1 por lo tanto estas dos que están
pintadas en azul tienen que ser 1 bueno
multipliquemos a ambos lados de esta
ecuación por ea la x
en el lado izquierdo nos quedamos con
esta expresión la derivada de la equis
ahora multiplicando a ambos lados de la
igualdad por ea la x nos da a la x entre
a la x elijo ponerlo de este lado en
este término esto es igual a ea la x
este lado es 1 por lo tanto lo
eliminamos ahora sí estamos listos puede
que no sea completamente satisfactorio
para ti pero funciona la derivada de ea
la x es igual a ea la x
y bueno yo creo que todo el país y tu
escuela y en general todo mundo debería
tomarse unas vacaciones para pensar en
este resultado que además de ser
fascinante en un futuro no muy lejano
nos llevará a conclusiones realmente
dramáticas
bueno independientemente de lo que pase
o no nos vemos en el próximo vídeo